حين تعهد رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيعي
السوداني في طهران ابي ضبط امن الحدود شكك
المرشد الايراني بذلك ويبدو ان هذا الملف
ليس الوحيد الذي يشكك فيه خامنئي اعترف
خلال لقائه بالسوداني في طهران لفشل
مذكرات التفاهم والتعاون بين البلدين
وانها لم تصل الى مرحله العمل والعهده هنا
على ايران انترناشونال
يريد اذا تحركا عمليا في مجال التعاون
الاقتصادي والتبادل البضائع والسكك
الحديديه يدفع المرشد الى هذا الاتجاه
ولابد من المزيد لكن لماذا الاجابه في
مباحثات اعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي
الايرانيه المؤشرات ليست في صالح طهران
لكن الى اي مدى تتغلغل ايران في الاقتصاد
العراقي لديها اذرع اقتصاديه
او وجدت بيئه خارجيه تتحرك فيها طهران ريا
وهي المؤسسات الايرانيه في العراق
اعاده الاعمار بوابه الشركات الايرانيه
للهيمنه الاستثماريه والخدميه ايضا مهمه
الحشد يعد السعاده المناطق من داعش هي منح
عمليات اعاده الاعمار في تلك المدن
للشركات الايرانيه فهل هناك منافسه لا
وتحسمها قوه السلاح
شركاتنا في جميع المجالات مثلا في مجال
المقاولات لو ارادت شركه عراقيه او اجنبيه
المنافسات ستصطدم لشبكه ايرانيه منها شركه
الكوثر التي اسسها فيلق القدس في 2003 وفي
مجال الطاقه الاصطدام سيكون بشركات
ايرانيه ومنها شركه مبنى التابعه لوزاره
الطاقه الايرانيه